see these hairs on sully's arm from
monsters inc
instead of animating each hair one by
one pixar computer scientists created a
program called fizz tea
which would automate the movement of
sully's hairs based on what's happening
in any given scene
pixar would later use the same system to
simulate realistic fur
on animal characters like remy the rat
and doug the dog
every single pixar movie brought at
least one groundbreaking innovation
each changing the future of animation
and movie making as a whole
let's look at how every pixar movie
brought animation
into the future
[Music]
computer graphics were around in the 80s
in small doses
but to make fully animated movies like
toy story the industry needed software
that could render complex
animations rendering is when a computer
takes all the info about an animation
the different algorithms for color
motion pattern
light shadow and effects and basically
films the movie
in the late 80s some of pixar's top
researchers got together to design
render man a program that combines all
the 3d assets created for each frame of
a movie and
translates them into a film quality
photo realistic
final image toy story wasn't the first
movie to use render man
but it was the first ever 3d animated
feature film
and the only way pixar could render the
whole movie was with render man
which shows how the software
revolutionized animation
since then render man has been the final
step in the production pipeline behind
every single pixar film and many
non-pixar films too
in fact it became the industry standard
for rendering and the first software
product to be awarded
an oscar
in 1998 a bug's life presented a
different challenge
creating characters with a smooth
texture and fluid lifelike movements
for years 3d models both in cg animated
movies and video games had been mapped
with polygons
that made some characters come out
looking patchy like andy in toy story
whose hand isn't smooth like a human
hand should be
so in a bug's life pixar's artists
applied a modeling technique they used
on their oscar-winning short
jerry's game this was called the
subdivision technique which one of
pixar's founders helped invent
it's when a modeling artist subdivides a
hard-edged shape
enough times that it appears as a smooth
surface
a bug's life was the first feature film
to use subdivision
which worked especially well on
hard-bodied insects like ants to create
glossy textures
and the team was able to experiment with
one soft creature
a bavarian caterpillar named heimlich
see all his smooth curves and rolls
that's thanks to subdivision which made
it possible to create this type of plump
squishy bug
this technology would eventually be used
for almost every object in pixar films
and like render man subdivision became a
standard technique in the industry
later helping to create cg characters in
live action movies
like gollum in the second and third lord
of the rings
if you look back at andy in the original
toy story you'll notice his flesh looks
a little too
similar to the plastic surfaces on his
toys it lacks
detail for toy story 2 pixar wanted to
give andy his mom and the new humans in
the story more natural skin
so the studio created a major addition
to render man
a shader this added tool set helped
pixar shading artists paint layers of
detail over the basic renderings of
characters
like real life makeup artists they could
now give humans unique skin
characteristics like pores
veins sweat redness whiteheads
moles whiskers or a five o'clock shadow
making them look less plastic and more
alive
pixar had to create some very furry
monsters for monsters inc
including the eight-foot tall sullivan
who had nearly three million hairs on
his body
animating every strand of hair one by
one would have been
impossible especially since sully
appears in over 600 shots
so pixar set up a department dedicated
to simulation
a way to automate the movement of
elements like hair fur and clothing
the team also built a simulator engine
called fizz t
which calculates for example how hair
moves with the character's movements
or how hairs collectively respond to
forces like gravity wind or snow
pixar has used fizz t on every one of
its movies since then to give realistic
movement to everything from human flesh
to the suckers on an octopus
pixar moved underwater for finding nemo
so the studio had to nail the appearance
of
light passing through objects in the
ocean like the several thousand
jellyfish
in this sequence these jellies called
for different shading than any other
creature pixar had worked on
as cg supervisor lisa forsell said the
team didn't want the jellyfish to look
transparent like a window
or translucent like a shower curtain
their membrane needed to resemble
bathroom glass
where you can see through it but it's
all distorted and blurry
so pixar wrote a whole new shading
system called translurency
which blurred the background of objects
based on their depth and distance from
the viewer
calculating camera position and optical
light paths into the equation
you can see how the background is most
blurred in the middle of the jellyfish
and least blurred on the edges of its
bell
that's true to the way light refracts
through a jellyfish's membrane
and it captures that bathroom window
effect they were going for
incredibles was pixar's first movie with
an entirely human cast of characters
and when it came to building those
characters none of them were harder
literally than this one bob
better known as mr incredible would be
the most
muscular character pixar had ever
created
so the studio came up with a completely
new approach to his layers of skeleton
muscle and fat the team designed a type
of muscle rig
called goo that let a character's skin
respond to their moving muscles
better yet animators could see this
response in real time as they moved
their character around
this led to breakthroughs and body parts
that had always been problematic in
animation like the shoulders
until this point pixar had stuck with
characters that have more primitive
shoulders
look at buzz whose shoulder consists of
a ball and socket
or woody who just has a stitch where his
arm hinges off his body
using goo animators could master the
tiny details of mr incredible's much
more complex shoulder movement like how
his trapezius muscle affects his
pectoral muscle
once the rigging and modeling team
perfected bob they could use his
skeleton as a template
reshaping the muscle rig to fit other
characters and giving them
equally complex motion
in real life a car would look weird if
it didn't have any reflections on its
surface
but translating this on screen can get
complicated
especially for a movie like cars see
shiny cars reflect
other shiny cars which makes for a lot
of reflections at play in scenes like
this one
the only way pixar could master all
these reflective metal surfaces
was with ray tracing a technique of
mapping out all the rays of light in a
scene
as they bounce off walls objects and
characters
pixar first used ray tracing in two
shots of a bug's life to create the
reflections on a glass bottle
but it only became a main part of the
rendering process with cars
where it was used to create the sharp
shadows and detailed reflections the
filmmakers needed
ray tracing transformed animation it
even ended up on cgi elements in live
action movies
like this transformer or iron man suit
and it set the stage for even more
complex lighting in future pixar movies
like monsters university
in ratatouille all the dishes had to
look absolutely delicious
so the shading art and lighting team
studied food photography to figure out
what exactly makes food
look good on camera they determined that
a lot of a dish's visual appeal boils
down to the appearance of softness
which comes from light passing through
the food see a lot of foods are actually
kind of translucent
which means some light will go through
the surface of the material scatter
around
and then reflect back pixar already had
a way of replicating this effect a
technique for rendering translucent
materials called subsurface scattering
this tool modeled light scattering
outwards through the surface of the food
but the filmmakers were still going for
a more translucent look
and wanted to show light going straight
through the food as well
so they developed a new type of light
called gummy based partly on the gummy
bear-like quality of
marlin and nemo in finding nemo take
this shot of cheese grapes and bread
the cheese in this first shot has no
lighting with the subsurface scattering
you can see the outer edges and top
layers illuminated
and finally with gummy the light
permeates every layer of the cheese to
give it a
soft diffused glow they used this
approach on entire shelves of
cheese and vegetables as well as on
liquids like wine
together subsurface scattering and gummy
created a two-part translucency effect
that made sure
no food item would look waxy hard or
plastic on screen
on the old pixar camera any tilt or pan
was a two-dimensional move
without any change in perspective but
wall-e's filmmakers
wanted the viewer's perspective to shift
when the virtual camera did
so it feel like the camera was actually
moving in space
so they rebuilt their camera system
modeling it on the way an anamorphic
camera would move and consulting with a
live
action cinematographer a first for any
pixar film
the first act of the movie went for a
loose handheld feel
designed to look like it was shot from a
camera operator's shoulder
the second and third axe are supposed to
look like they're shot with a steady cam
and since a camera never moves perfectly
in real life director andrew stanton
said his team spent probably
90 percent of their time putting little
imperfections into the virtual camera
there are shots where the focus lags
tracking shots with a little bump in the
camera movement
and scenes where it feels like the
camera person sees something and catches
it a few frames later
the result is perfectly imperfect
in up carl's canopy of balloons is
central to the storyline
it involved thousands of colorful
balloons each attached to the chimney of
carl's house by a string
with thousands of collisions going on at
any given moment
and when one balloon bumped into another
the second one would bump into a third
balloon and so on
at the time pixar's physical simulator
could only handle about 500 balloons
so the effects department wrote a new
program to run under the simulator
using newton's laws of motion the
computer accounted for forces acting on
the balloons in every shot
and then decided how each balloon should
move it also made sure that all the
balloons were buoyant that their strings
were attached and that the wind was
blowing through them in a realistic way
for every single frame of animation
ultimately pixar simulator was powerful
enough to handle
10 297 balloons
toy story 3 brought together a bigger
cast of characters
three times as many as in the original
movie
costuming all of them wouldn't be easy
especially when introducing characters
like bonnie who wears three different
outfits in the movie
or ken who changes costumes in every
scene
to dress them all pixar needed a faster
way of making clothes
traditionally the studio used a 2d
garment tailoring system that required
artists with special tailoring skills
to cut out pieces of cloth and stitch
them together in the computer
toy story 3 used a new 3d cloth system
that let
any modeling artists not just expert
digital tailors
sculpt garments like a taylor would in
the real world and then turn those
garments into simulatable clothes
since more modelers could build garments
pixar's artists could dress
over 300 animated characters for toy
story 3
compared to the 76 in the first movie
the filmmakers behind cars 2 envisioned
it
as a jason bourne style spy movie where
the cars would race around cities from
london to tokyo
they wanted to reproduce those settings
with a level of detail that was
10 times what pixar had put into any
other film
for one of the movie's biggest sequences
that meant making specific
improvements to the way pixar depicted
waves
technology from finding nemo was best
suited for calmer waters
but in cars 2 the filmmakers wanted to
show rough
high waves slamming into the sides of
the boat
they came up with an ocean generator
called tessendorf
which used algorithms to simulate
sharper cuspier waves that captured the
danger of an ocean's choppy surface
with this pixar could better convey the
physics of the natural world
and pushed its water simulation to the
next level
detailed realistic simulation became the
company's calling card
continuing with the curly hair in brave
we'll get to that
in part two
[Music]
you